[Musique]
et on revient forcément Michel sur cet
épisode neigeux puisque ce soir les
ivelines sont toujours en vigilance
orange neigeeverglet les autorités
appellent à la prudence oui Météo France
maintient la vigilance orange neige
Vergl jusqu'à demain 6h du matin dans un
communiqué de presse la préfecture des
ivelines appelle à la plus grande
prudence sur les routes la vitesse est
limitée à 70 km/h sur les axes
principaux les dépassements sont
interdits pour les véhicules de plus de
7 5 tonnes vous pouvez vous renseigner
sur les conditions de circulation sur le
site internet
m.citadin.fr ou encore privilégier les
transport en commun pour faciliter le
passage des engins de dégagement des
routes il est également demandé de
stationner en dehors des voies de
circulation soyez également prudent si
vous rencontrez des fils électriques
tombés au sol autre information si vous
habitez l'une des communes de 50 an
Livine et que vous souhaitez être alerté
par SMS des interventions de celleuses
ou des chutes de neige à prévoir vous
vous pouvez vous abonner au portail
espace public service de Saint-Quentin
en Livine et d'ailleurs on a reçu la
petite alerte puisque la prochain le
prochain passage des déneigeuses est
prévu pour ce soir cette nuit même à 4h
du matin vigilance donc à maintenir les
conditions s'améliorent malgré la galère
pour certains aujourd'hui la la neige
nous a tout de même offert quelques
belles images oui Grégory lesilin revêtu
un joli manteau blanc cette nuit nous
offront parfois de beaux paysages
ennéigés je vousoulais contempler ces
quelques
[Musique]
images
bon on a le droit à ces images quasiment
une fois par an mais à chaque fois c'est
vrai qu'on on ne finit pas de s'en
émerveiller alorsux on en prend plein
les yeux effectivement on a un très beau
département aussi il faut le dire autre
actualité Michel vous allez nous parler
à présent des des tensions qui règnent
dans la commune de maniléamoau oui hier
soir Bertrand Houillon le maire de la
commune présenta ses vœux 2024 aux
habitants parmi les sujets abordés la
construction d'une mosquée qui avait
suscité la polémique en décembre dernier
pour Rael la mairie projetéit de
permettre la construction d'un lieu de
culte musulman porté par l'association
des musulmans de maniléamo le projet
avait suscité de nombreuses
interrogations chez les manquois l'un
d'entre eux ayant notamment été menacé
de mort sur les réseaux sociaux le maire
s'est exprimé à ce sujet au micro de
Julien Laura je condamnerai toujours
toutes les menaces d'où qu'elles
viennent et pour qui que ce soit euh
j'ai redit un appel à l'apaisement et à
la sérénité puisque c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne à maniléamo c'est du vivre
ensemble et queles que soient les
diversités dans lesqueles on est on
accepte tout le monde point final alors
c'est vrai que j'en ai pas parlé je suis
resté très silencieux toutes ces
dernières semaines ça fait 4 semaines
que je reçois des injures des mises en
cause de mon intégrité des diffamations
des messages aussi d'incitation à la
haine et à la violence et puis des
menaces mais là-dessus je le gère avec
la gendarmerie avec les services de la
préfecture avec la justice et ça ira
pour le moment le projet de construction
reste maintenu dans la commune on
termine ces informations du jour Michel
avec une bonne nouvelle bonne nouvelle
pour l'école 2600 oui vous le savez
grégoryi la cybersécurité représente un
grand enjeu pour le 21e siècle comment
protéger nos ordinateurs nos téléphones
ou tout système électronique contre des
attaques malveillantes l'école 2600
située à montinille Breton il travaille
ardemment elle a d'ailleurs été nommée
meilleure école de France en cyber
sécurité on écoute la réaction du
directeur général adjoint on a été
reconnu meilleure école cyber de
France lors de la cyberna 2023 par la
République Haïti donc c'est un prix qui
a été quand même décerné par un jury de
800 professionnels eu à l'issue de cette
formation d'excellence l'objectif pour
nous c'est que sur le marché de l'emploi
nos étudiants mais pas que tout individu
toute entreprise qui cherche à pousser
ses salariés vers l'excellence en
matière de la cyber puisse le faire au
travers de notre plateforme de formation
continue d'ici 2030 l'école 2600 veut
former 10000 personnes sur trois
disciplines principales la cybersécurité
la sécurité défensive offensive et la
gouvernance une ambition primordiale
quand on sait que la pénurie de compéten
en terme de cybersécurité persiste dans
le monde merci Michel pour toutes ces
informations et comme d'habitude si vous
aussi près de chez vous vous êtes
témoins d'une actualité qui vous fait
réagir dans les Evelin n'hésitez pas à
nous la partager sur les réseaux sociaux
en utilisant le hashtag 78 news